hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new series today we are going to be
flipping random items so how this is
going to work is we are going to be
rolling a dice essentially a 3,900 sided
dice and uh taking that number that
number is going to correspond with an a
sellable item in the RuneScape database
and then we're going to flip the item um
with a couple restrictions but for the
most part we will take the random item
and we'll try to make something of it so
the restrictions are going to be I'm
going to start with 1 mil so the item
has to be under 1 mil and um once I get
the item I'm going to buy use all the
money I can to buy the item or until I
hit the buying limit if I hit the buying
limit I'll just flip that full amount
and then move on to another item I'm
going to have a couple lifelines as in
skips so one skip is going to be um not
really going to be used this episode
it'll be used next episode because what
it's going to involve is an audience
suggestion so leave your guys'
suggestions down below for items under 1
mil um that I could flip anything you
want so really really anything at all
and um basically if I don't want to do
the item here I will randomly pick one
from the comment section
instead uh the second skip I've come up
with will just be a reroll and then I
get to pick between the two items so I
get a new item but I still have the
option of doing the other one if the new
one is even shittier than the first one
um but yeah let's get into it guys I
hope you enjoyed and we're going to do
five flips this episode okay so we got 1
mil in the inventory let's get started
with the first item so we'll get our
random number generator open
here and we will generate a couple
numbers well just one 208 so we'll go
over here to our spreadsheet pretty
close by already 208 is the soul Rune
okay that's actually a decent item to
start on uh next in the process we're
just going to look if there is a limit
posted and which there is
10,000 and we'll go check it on ow
buddy
and yeah we kind of looked it on this
item oh man because there's a whole
whack load of shitty items so we bought
them for
297 and we're going to sell them
[Music]
for
288 it's actually pretty decent so we'll
go ahead and buy the soul Rune 288
and we can afford
3,472 Soul runes so let's do this and
we'll come back when they have
sold okay so we have sold these Soul
runs I can see here we're sold them for
295 making us about 24K so not too bad
actually um I was kind of worried they
were going to crash down cuz they were
so much higher than regular are but we
managed to sell them in time so let's
get our second item so we'll get the
random generator going
again
generate 13
interesting 13 is adamant arot tips okay
not too bad okay so we bought one for
95 and we sold it for 85 this seems
pretty decent uh
regularly okay that seems decently in
line so we'll go ahead and
buy we'll do
10,000 okay so we're getting pretty
close here um we'll buy
12,50 how
about Perfect all right we'll come back
when some of this has bought okay so the
a tips have sold uh we did hit the
buying limit at 10K so we actually did
add that to our list uh which is cool
but anyway we sold them for pretty much
95 each uh by pretty much I mean
exactly and uh we made about 8 100K
that's actually pretty decent uh for um
just a random item anyway uh so we'll go
ahead and get another item as well so
this will be item number
three okay let's see what the random
generator
says
86 actually a lot low numbers here 86 is
Grimmy martil okay uh still not not the
worst by far um grimy
martil see I even have herbs
here no but I think they have a 2K limit
but we will go double
check uh actually 12K limit okay uh so
we'll go ahead and do some grimy Mar
I'm just guessing it's going to have a 1
GP limit on it or 1 GP
margin yes okay grimy Marin
till five each and
uh okay
well this is going to be a very lwi
income flip uh we'll do 30k just to
prove that we hit to limit and yeah
we'll come back when they have sold okay
so the grimy maritals have finally sold
we capped it out about
9.2k we're going to go for the buying
limits worth but these were taking
forever to buy luckily they did sell
pretty quickly anyway we got a 1gp
margin given us about 5.5k uh so not
that great but uh you know whatever okay
let's hit the generate button and it is
1358 let's have a
look okay looks like we got the kill's
crossbow
zero let's have a look at that cill
Carill
Carill crossbow zero okay this will be
an interesting
item so it is a
1200k item that's not too bad and 66 a
day okay uh we are going
to put an offering for a boat H seems
been going
up all right let's
see
Krill
carols crossbow
zero it's saying 106 here 115 here okay
we'll start off by putting it in for
these actively trade price uh
17400 H
about
and uh we'll do 10 after long last we
have finally sold these car's Carol's
crossbows um so long I got impatient you
can see my buying history is totally for
other stuff uh but I bought them for
115k and finally sold them for
116k so we ended up getting 9k off that
shitty shitty lengthy flip I should have
skipped that one I didn't realize it
would take so long to sell it cuz no is
buying Carol's crossbow empty or used or
whatever they call it anyway we finally
on to our final flip of the episode flip
number five let's roll a number between
what is that again 32
46 and we've actually yet to get
something too expensive which is
interesting
207 207 is
the blood Rune actually that's quite
nice so we didn't end up having to use
any of our skips uh for this episode
because we'll definitely do the blood
run uh but again for next time guys
submit some items that are under 1 mil
and um it can be anything anything at
all doesn't have to be good but if I
don't want to do the item here I will
use my lifeline per se and pick a random
item that you guys have suggested and I
will do it assuming it's under 1
mil okay so the blood Rune actually
pretty nice to finish the episode off
see what the margin is on that
currently
262 and 260 okay not huge margin but
um still way better than that last piece
of
[__] 260 and I know they have a 10K
buying limit but I cannot get that many
that's pretty close
actually and yeah that sounds good we
did about 4.4k and we will come back
when we have sold this okay we are back
guys and we have sold all the blood
runes and we managed to actually get a
3gp profit uh which is still not super
great uh but anyway we will claim our
money and see much we made we made about
155k so that is actually pretty good
considering they are absolutely random
items essentially someone could have
scripted a bot to do this I know all I
did was buy the most of the item I could
and just use a margin didn't matter what
it was I did anyway and I still made
155k uh which is still pretty impressive
uh on the blood runes we made about 12
14k actually uh I think we got a little
lucky with the items but again who
really knows it was totally up to chance
so it doesn't actually look like like I
use any of the skips this episode but
next time I definitely will um so leave
your suggestions for items under 1 mil
that I could attempt to flip uh it's
okay if it's a troll item I mean
preferably it is actually uh cuz it's
not meant to be a reward for using these
Skip it's kind of a last resort kind of
thing so that was my one idea the other
one will just be I roll the item and
then pick between the two if you have
any suggestions um for lifelines I could
do just leave a comment down below as
well and yeah I hope you enjoyed and
thanks for watching watching guys I will
see you guys in the next
episode